The Joe Rogan Experience I feel I feel
bad for like this next Generation
because I don't even think they realize
that you know what's happening with that
it's just that that addiction to your
phone that's really what I think it's
going to be is eventually we're gonna
everyone's gonna have this sort of
opinion and attitude because people are
starting to get wind of it that it's bad
to be to be on your phone that much
um and I think just parents are gonna
just start saying like yeah no you can't
be on a [__] cell phone all day you
can't be and I think it comes down to us
I think we have to make a decision to do
that with our kids
yeah you got to teach them discipline
for sure but also recognize that
everyone is using these things and it's
a part of Civilization now
I I really feel like if we could see the
writing on the wall we would be
terrified I I think human beings are
were slipping into some weird place
where we're
for sure within the next few years going
to be connected to computers
oh yeah how we're going to do it I don't
know how they're going to do it whether
it's something you wear or something
that's in you
but it's common kids
and it's almost like all these things
are falling in line at the same time
like all these uh endocrine disruptors
and Plastics that are [__] up
people's reproductive systems
and then at the same time we're all
getting addicted to phones and not as
personal you know because people aren't
really communicating hanging out just
talking to each other without checking
their phone every time but it's going to
be the future is going to be us looking
at each other and downloading each
other's thoughts oh [__] because you
could air drop pictures and [__] now
it's literally gonna be like here take
this picture just with a [__] thought
yeah that and it will 100 is gonna
happen they're already they're already
doing [__] right they're already making
devices that can go in your body that
connect to other [__] I'm sure I'm sure
it's so much more advanced than we even
know think about how much we don't know
right there's got to be some crazy [__]
going on out there for sure really
unethical [__]
that's going on right now hey what is um
like what was that I want to see Elon
Musk basement was the experiments that
he has going on right now it's probably
18 miles deep
um what what is that uh thing they did
where they uh where they recorded uh
human thoughts like someone was watching
something and they got a recording of
that
from something this person was where I
saw it I saw it yeah bro that is that is
like just think Morse code was not that
long ago
that was not that long ago yeah and it
seems like technology will just move now
with AI it's just it's yeah it's just
moving faster and faster and faster it's
like it's really cool but it's also
[__] terrifying that's the [__] that
I'm terrified [__] asteroids dude this
[__] that we're talking about right now
is the [__] that keeps me up at night no
is this it scientists recorded a Pink
Floyd song from patients brain waves
yeah this is it the tech could
eventually allow for communication
without words what
100 of these egg heads keep going we're
[__] oh yeah dude it's we're gonna be
doing crazy [__] that's the really like
and then you gotta figure like it's
gonna be who's rich who has the best you
know computer built into their body
because the same the same guy who can
afford you know a [__] Lamborghini
yeah he's gonna have a super brain you
know and his computer is going to be
faster than your computer he's going to
be able to download and upload
information faster than you it's kind of
wild like that you're gonna have to be
an early adopter
right you would have to be like one of
the people who gets the brain operation
first and then you'd be like way ahead
of everybody yeah but that first one
dude the night before the operation are
you sure this is gonna work Harry yeah
Harry look me in the eye you're gonna
cut it into my brain are you sure
pretty sure I don't want it here pretty
sure Harry
yeah dude any dude it's [__] nut
that's like those people on that uh that
went on that um you know the [__]
submarine thing yeah Titanic dude it's
like yeah what a cool thing that must
have been to like sign up for you like
dude we're gonna go to see the Titanic
and then
that's [__] wild dude that could have
been you Joe you could have been down on
that thing no not a [__] chance in
hell was there was one was it Mr Beast
he said that they invited him to go do
it I am not hopping in that [__]
backyard smoker and dropping to the
bottom of the ocean would you go to
space right now I'm like one of these
Charters
son you love space those things blow up
you have to go real fast to go into
space kid those things blow up
I'm not interested not until they get
that [__] down like an electric car when
they get a spaceship that moves like a
Tesla just yeah okay I'm in
yeah just not worth it I get it look
your starry nights are beautiful I get
it yeah I get it I get you'd want to
like go out get real high and come back
down I'm good you can [__] keep that
I trust that it's up there I don't have
to jump at the top of a cliff I'm good
I'll just sit down and look at it from
here like even as high as we get like
what we're calling space like look we've
made it into space we're like [__]
that far off the Earth's surface yeah
this is so much is that what uh is that
what the those tours are you just go
into space for a second uh you just go
like well come back down no like you
don't like go to space I want to go land
on the moon I want to check out Mars
you're not going to Jupiter yeah
[__] Dodge some [__] asteroids you
know what I bet they will be able to do
probably really soon is to give you a VR
representation of what it would be like
to travel through space Oh I bet it
already exists I I went I had um
yeah there was a NASA thing that I had
on my Oculus yeah that was good it was
super cool I mean it was like it was
just a movie essentially it wasn't like
I didn't get to like free move but it
was like I was on like um like a space
station type thing so you were like
moving all over it was really really
cool is this it no what is this chairman
I just looked up space tripped outer
space that's the first thing that popped
up get the [__] out Joe you would go
like that I'm looking this is a space
elevator and it's gonna fall and
everyone okay so you got a little bit of
extra bro I am not going in a [__]
before comfortable what if it gets hit
by an asteroid this looks like your
studio Jeff oh my God it does podcast in
a balloon no GeForce no listen you got
it that they have to do it a thousand
times before I even think about doing it
a six hour cocktails six hour Journey
see that's crazy if the if it's bro I am
not going up there perfect place
perfect place to fall to your death
like how many how many [__]
fail-saves
do you do nothing for the record I'm
sure it's safe yeah do you do anything
dangerous like uh dollars
125.000. oh it what
refundable deposit so 125 Grand to go up
in a balloon yeah
yeah well I hope it works in six hours I
feel like that's kind of disappointing
if like space should be more than six
hours away in a balloon I'm scared of
anything that people are trying out like
flying cars I'm like just drive that for
a while
you you drive it for a while yeah I'll
be over here even like this just the
self-driving cars that [__] go like
you hear about once in a while they'll
just [__] go Haywire like mistakes
happen yes mistakes happen and then
you're just in a car that you can't
[__] stop and it's like mowing people
down this and I never I have a Tesla I
never put the self-driving on yeah
I mean I do sometimes when I'm on the
highway just for goofies yeah it just
drives itself I keep my hands on it so
it's it completely self-drives yeah
completely self-drives up to a point but
I don't let it you know it's just it's
just to me it's just like I'd rather
just be really tuned into what I'm doing
and paying attention yeah